all right let's look at what it looks
like when a non-religious person who is
a republican tries to Pander to
religious voters it's actually quite
depressing Donald Trump appeared on the
I never fully understand what show this
is the flashpoint victory
show it's a religious Christian thing
and it's actually hilarious what happens
they one of the questions is framed
about how important Trump's faith is to
him and it's really funny because
obviously it's not true Trump has never
been religious but he's started to
pretend to be religious because he ran
as a republican this just gets like
really awkward and Trump spits out a
word salad about religion your faith is
very important to you you've said that
publicly your faith is important Trump
has said a lot of things that aren't
true but what does that mean to the man
Donald Trump well I think it means a lot
of things but more to perhaps your
listeners and the people that will watch
this show it's a very large group of
people uh for instance I was the only
president ever go go to go to the big
rally they had in Washington right which
they have on a yearly basis but I guess
he means the March for Life I guess the
only one ever to go as a president
sitting president for life and people
were shocked but even Ronald Reagan and
didn't want to take that step and it was
very close always very close as you know
to the White House it's almost like
walking distance but I went and I was
proud of that I think we've been given
credit for doing that but you can tell
Trump is deeply religious deeply
spiritual from this answer people would
say that was a courageous thing to do I
think you were just courageous I
reviewed it as the right thing to do but
I was born into a family where my father
was religious my mother was religious uh
I wouldn't say they were you know going
to church every single day they were you
know they were believers they were very
privately religious such that no one
knew it even me and and strong believers
I went to Sunday school
which was good and which was expected
you know it's like you everybody goes to
story school right and when you think
about it the world is so different now
anyway so you know you get the just they
slammed Hillary Clinton for adopting a
sort of Southern drawl when she would
speak in front of some Southern crowds
in my mind that's nothing compared to
pretending to be devoutly religious and
against abortion when clearly you you
aren't and you haven't been your entire
life Trump of course there's no you
never waste the opportunity to claim
that the left is simply against religion
they're against religion they're totally
against religion how do you get elected
on these things they get elected by
cheating right of course the truth is
what my listen you can ask different
people on the left you'll get different
answers I'm against religion playing a
role in civil government I love freedom
of religion freedom to follow any
religious doctrine that speaks to you or
not to follow any and to have none of
that impact public policy nor how you
were treated under the law that's what
I'm for as a member of the left I'm not
against religion Trump then said he's
the only person who can stop Israel from
getting nuked by Iran which is
interesting and there's a lot to say
about this
under the Democrats Israel will be
destroyed because Iran will have a
nuclear weapon and they'll destroy
Israel they will use it too so when you
say I fight I fight because we have no
choice we have no choice
and there's nobody else I don't believe
that knows
how to do this right so it's really
important to understand that the way in
which Trump supporters are quote
pro-israel is a very specific thing from
the Evangelical Christian Community the
the viewers of this show okay the
viewers of this show support Israel not
because of any concern about
anti-Semitism or Jews or it's because
they believe that supporting Israel will
precipitate the second coming of Christ
after which most or all of the Jews die
depending on which belief system you
adhere to that's why they are quote
supporters of Israel and that's what
Trump is paying lip service to and then
lastly Trump saying the Johnson
amendment is a terrible thing if you
don't know what that is I'll tell you in
a moment I'm asking why don't you use
your power
so that you can be treated better
and then one person said well we have
the Johnson Amendment which basically
would take our tax exemption and our tax
basis away from us and which is
unbelievably severe we put put you out
of business
I said so that actually the people and I
was at the top of Trump Tower way up
high and I looked down at the sidewalk
and you see all the people I said so
anybody off the street then you're
saying has more power than the people in
this room because okay so let me explain
to you what Trump is saying here the
Johnson amendment is a tax code
provision from 1954. when we say
non-profit churches aren't allowed to do
politics or they jeopardize their
tax-exempt status what we're talking
about partially comes from the Johnson
Amendment the Johnson Amendment said if
you're a 501c3 nonprofit organization
you can't endorse or oppose political
candidates and of course as We Know
dozens and dozens hundreds thousands of
churches particularly Evangelical
churches
um and other forms of Christianity
protestantism regularly do politics and
often overtly endorse or oppose
candidates they should lose their
tax-exempt status Trump is saying no
it's too harsh because then it actually
uh makes them impotent in some way
relative to random people well the whole
point is we will give you something
special something privileged under the
tax code which is non-profit status but
you can't engage in politics because
that's a way to circumvent all of the
campaign Finance infrastructure that is
there for a particular reason so Trump
doesn't like that Trump wants to get rid
of that this is the height
or the bottom of the barrel depending on
your view of pandering to a group of
Voters that yes Trump does need he
rightly assesses that he needs them in
the most pathetic way possible
by now all of us know how creepy it is
to talk to a friend about something and
then get ads that are related when you
use a free email service from a big Tech
Corporation your emails are scanned even
if you're emailing your spouse or your
doctor which is why I recommend start
mail the email service that never scans
or analyzes your email our sponsor start
mail also lets you create unlimited
email address aliases so you don't even
have to give out your real email address
this protects you from spam and phishing
attacks phishing attacks are becoming
way more sophisticated with the rise of
chat GPT by the way start mail lets you
encrypt any email you send even if the
recipient isn't using encryption unlike
the big Tech email Services who store
even your deleted emails when you delete
an email in start mail it is gone
migrating from your current email
service to start mail is just a few
clicks so what are you waiting for stop
letting big Tech corporations spy on
your email my audience gets 50 off your
first year at startmail.com Pacman the
link is down below